hello and thank you for joining us for
this live webinar characterization and
affinity maturation of TCR mimic SC FES
identified using phage display I am Sam
Bob Dave from AB camp and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab Rhodes the leading scientific social
network networking web site and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by app cam as an
innovator in reagents and tools at cams
purpose is to serve life signs
researchers globally to achieve their
mission faster providing the research
and clinical communities with tools and
scientific support we offer highly
validated biological binders and assays
to address important targets in
critically biological pathways to learn
more visit WWF champion so let's get
started you can you can ask questions to
the speakers during the presentation
while they are fresh in your mind
to do so simply type them in the Q&A box
which will open when you click the green
Q&A button at the lower left hand side
of the presentation window the questions
will be answered after both
presentations to enlarge the slide
window click on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you experience any technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button at the top right hand side of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left hand side this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the C e button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your webpage and we
will follow the process of obtaining
your credits
I now present today's speaker
Jacquie Douglas from Johns Hopkins
School of Medicine
Jackie completed her bachelor's degree
in chemical biological engineering and
economics and a master's degree in
chemical engineering practice at MIT she
is currently an MD PhD candidate at
Johns Hopkins School of Medicine and is
doing her PhD thesis in the lab of Bert
vogelstein Jackie's pieces involves
using phage display to identify TCR
mimic SCF ease or antibody fragments
recognizing mutant peptide HLA complexes
and translating these SC FPS into
therapeutic formats
Jackie will now begin her presentation -
Brad thanks so much for your
introduction so my name is Jackie
Douglas and I'm a graduate student at
Johns Hopkins University in the lab of
Bert vogelstein and today I'll be
talking to you guys about
characterization and affinity maturation
of TCR mimic SC Effy's identified using
phage display the first and outline of
my talk today I'll first provide an
overview of what TCR olymic SEO fees are
and how they might be useful for cancer
therapy and then I'll provide an
overview of phage display and the
panning process which is how we go about
identifying RSVPs and then finally I'll
provide a case study for one antigen of
interest
it's a K R sg-12 e mutant peptide folded
into hlaa 2 and specifically I'll talk
about how we identified an S CFE
recognizing this antigen and how we went
about characterizing that sec and
affinity maturing it so we are
interested in targeting something called
antigen processing and presentation all
nucleated cells in the body expressed
class 1 HLA or human leukocyte antigen
and this can more generally be referred
to in other species as MHC or a major
histocompatibility complex and so in
proteins and the seller degraded by the
proteasome a fraction of the resulting
we'll be taken up into the endoplasmic
reticulum via the tap transporter where
they're loaded onto HLA molecules and
sent to the cell surface these peptide
HLA complexes serve as a way for the
immune system specifically t-cells to
sample the contents of that cell and
determine if that peptide is a felf
peptide or a foreign peptide so during
normal t-cell development the majority
of t-cells that recognize self peptides
are removed in the thymus and so only
peptides the vast majority cells in the
periphery are going to recognize foreign
peptides so I mentioned this is a
mechanism for immune system the immune
system to sample the contents of cells
and so for example if a cell is infected
with a virus some of the peptides on the
cell surface will be viral it will be
viral peptides and certain T cells that
have a T cell receptor or TCR that
recognize the sworen peptide will be
triggered to kill that virally infected
cell thus clearing the viral infection
so there's three classes there's three
class one HLA genes a B and C and these
genes are polymorphic but some alleles
are more common than others
so for example HLA a to is sounded
around forty to fifty percent of the
general population and HLA a1 a3 and b7
are also similarly very common and so
the reason that we're interested in this
pathway for cancer therapy is that a
fraction of intercellular mutations can
be presented extracellular li and this
would be a truly tumor specific marker
present on the cancer cell surface so
now I've modified the diagram to contain
the red star that represents a peptide
containing mutation and so it's possible
that peptides containing mutations will
be presented and as a mutant peptide HLA
complex
on the tumor cell surface so it turns
out that many cancer patients has been
shown in cancer patients that many of
them have anti-cancer t-cell responses
and that they have T cells with TC RS
recognizing these mutant peptide HLA
complexes and this can be protective
against cancer however the tumor
micro-environment tend to be very
immunosuppressive so drugs that are
involved in checkpoint blockades just
such as an T ctla-4 and anti pd-1
antibodies can help reverse the
suppressive tumor micro-environment
and take the brakes off the t-cells to
ramp up t-cells that have an anti-cancer
TCR however we know that the the vast
majority of patients and the majority of
cancer types checkpoint blockade drugs
are not enough and so that's where the
goal of our project comes in our goal is
to create TCR mimic antibodies targeting
peptides containing common driver gene
mutations presented in common HLA
alleles and that's because not all
patients have a strong enough endogenous
anti-cancer t-cell response we call our
antibodies Manta bodies for mutation
associated neo antigen antibodies so
importantly our antibodies must be
specific to the mutated peptide epitope
and not its wild-type counterpart and it
also must not recognize any other normal
peptide presented on a normal cell
surface and then once we identify an
antibody we could think about using a
variety of different therapeutic formats
so this diagram shows a full-length IgG
antibody full-length IgG antibodies work
either via an fatty dependent cellular
cytotoxicity called a DCC or complement
dependent cytotoxicity called CDC and
these are both fairly sensitive but
they're not necessarily the most
sensitive therapeutic formats and so
we're also looking at converting our
antibodies and Okarche
cells by specific antibodies and
antibody drug conjugates and so I
mentioned that we're interested in in
targeting mutant oncogene peptides and
now provide a little bit of background
why specifically were interested in
mutant oncogene peptides so cancer
cancer cells are driven by driver genes
driver genes can be broadly broken down
into two classes we have oncogenes which
have a gain of function mutation and
tumor suppressors which have a loss of
function mutation and because there's
typically there's fewer ways to induce a
gain of function and a protein than a
loss of function oncogenes tend to have
stronger hotspots hotspot mutations and
one of the most important oncogenes
that's mutated in cancer is chaos chaos
mutations are identified in around
130,000 new cases of cancer every year
these mutations are present in nearly
all cases of pancreatic cancer and
around 30% of colorectal cancers and
importantly for our purposes mutations
and codons 12 and 13 occur for the vast
majority of chaos associated cancers so
this pie chart from the cosmic database
shows the chaos mutation frequency and
you can see that the vast majority of
chaos mutations are correct codons 12
and 13 with G 12 D and G 12 v mutations
being the most common and a very small
fraction of chaos mutations are correct
codon 61 so to identify our mana bodies
we basically had two methods to choose
from there's two common methods that are
used to generate antibodies the most
traditional method is called monoclonal
hybridoma technology and that's where
you immunize the mouse with an antigen
and after a period of time you're going
to harvest spleen and isolate the
b-cells to produce a hybridoma and then
what you do is you screen the hybridoma
cells
to look for the hybridomas that produced
an antibody that with that does that
binds to your antigen of interest so
there were a couple downsides of using
hybridoma technology for our purposes
it's a slightly longer process it takes
around six to nine months to generate a
murine antibody and importantly for our
purposes you cannot customize in vivo
the selection process and I'll explain
exactly what I mean by that in the next
few slides there's a second method to
generate antibodies it's commonly used
is what's called phage display
technology so in phage display
technology what you do is you take a
whole library of different bacteria
phage so bacterial sage is just a virus
that only infects bacteria and this
library of different page in the library
different page each page presents on its
surface a different antibody fragment
and what you can do through a process
called panning is enriched for phage
that display an antibody fragment with
desired antigen binding properties so in
our case we're using an antibody
fragment referred to a single chain
referred to as a single chain variable
fragment or s vfe and that's where you
directly link together the variable
heavy region and the variable light
region of an antibody as a single chain
and this is a minimal bind the minimal
portion of the antibody that retains
antigen binding so faithfully technology
has several advantages
it only takes around one to three months
to generate a human antibody and if we
want to use these antibodies as
therapeutics they need to be human
humanized
and then finally for our purposes we can
customize the antibody selection process
and I'll explain what I mean that by
that and that's in the coming slides so
our man Abadi our man Abadi platform
consists of a number of steps first we
have identified common cancer mutations
and Driver genes particularly oncogene
and then we predict which peptides
containing those mutations will bind the
common HLA alleles so not all peptides
will bind to give an HLA allele test
hide binding is really dependent on the
N and c-terminal amino acids not peptide
and so we use online algorithms to
predict if a given peptide will bind to
a given HLA allele we've built a custom
SCC phage library and then we do a
process called competitive panning to
enrich for phage that present an SCO fee
that binds to our mutant peptide HLA
complex and then finally after we
identify phage hits we can sequence the
FCO fees and recombinant ly express the
SE of these and we use those for
commonly expressed SCO fees for
downstream assays which is Eliza and
cell based assays so now I'll go into a
little bit more detail about how phage
display works and what the painting
process entails
so the diagram shown shows an m13
bacteriophage this is when one of those
common commonly is type a phage per
phage display and what you'll notice is
that this page contains a phage mid DNA
surrounded by a number of different
viral coat proteins and what I want to
do is draw your attention to the p3 coat
protein on the left side of the screen
the p3 coat protein is present at five
copies on the phage particle surface and
this is typically used as a fusion
partner for an antibody fragment such as
an SCV
so to build our phage library we
generate a library of variant SCC
sequences and we sub cloned that library
into what's called a phage mid plasmid
such that the SCC DNA is just upstream
of a p3 protein DNA
then what we do is we transform the
stageman plasmid into e.coli and then we
infect that ecoli with health or phage
so the phage med plasmid provides the p3
coat protein but you have to Co infect
the e.coli with helper page to provide
all the other viral coat proteins as
well as the DNA packaging machinery and
thus we can produce our full phage
library so T is our phage library we do
a process called panning and panning you
take your phage library you incubate it
with an antigen of interest you wash
away in the unbound page and you can
elute any about round page using acidic
conditions and then we typically amplify
that eluted page by infecting eco light
with our eluded h and we grow up phage
overnight and we can repeat this panning
process multiple times to gradually and
rich for a specific sage now this
diagram shows positive selection where
we want phage that bind to a particular
antigen but you can also imagine doing
negative selection where you first
incubate your phage library with an
antigen that you do not want your phage
to bind to to remove any binders in each
age binders set design to that target
so our phage library as I mentioned is
an SCC based sage library and the
framework of the SC Fe is based on the
trustees and map Herceptin framework
this is also referred to as 45 the
reason we chose this framework is this
very stable and well characterized and
it's been shown to work well for other
previously published synthetic phage
libraries it's a fully human framework
and it's very similar to the canonical
human IgG one sequence and importantly
for our purposes it allows for stable
high levels of recombinant protein
expression so at the bottom of the
screen the bottom of the screen shows a
diagram of
cause of the fusion protein found in our
segment plasmid so at the end terminus
at the five-time end is a healthy leader
sequence followed by the SC of these
sequence and we have a Mick tag at
ee-vie cleavage site and a full-length
mm 13 p3 protein so in designing our SCC
phage library we wanted to add diversity
and the region's most important for
determining antigen specificity and
typically these are referred to as a
complimentary determining regions or
CDRs so this diagram shows a full-length
antibody there's two heavy chains and
green and two light chains in blue each
of the light chains and heavy chain has
three CDRs represented by the red lines
so in antibodies that would be produced
by the body and dodging ously it's the
CDR that are the most hyper variable and
thus determine antigen binding so one
another advantage of these in the forty
five framework is that the crystal
structure for the 45s CFE has been
solved and so we know which of the six
CDRs is exposed to solvents and this is
the most important for determining
antigen binding so of the six CDRs l3 h1
h2 and h3 are considered the most
important for antigen binding and so is
these four CDRs that we chose to vary in
our phage library so this table shows
the amino acid diversity and our library
in CDR l3 we only varied four positions
by two amino acids we introduced either
a searing or a tyrosine and these floors
positions however and the other CDRs we
had increasing amino acid diversity and
additionally you'll note in CDR h3
we also there's a delta symbol this
represents a random deletion of that
so at a certain probability we deleted
that position so that we have a variable
length diversity and CDR h3 as CDR h3 is
considered to be the most important for
antigen-binding so the DNA per our
library synthetic it's it was generated
using to generate oligonucleotide design
and it codes for the selected amino
acids shown in the table we outsource
the DNA synthesis for the library
however we constructed the library and
health and what I mean by this is we did
the e.coli transformation of the phage
mid plasmid in house followed by
infection with helper sage and design in
our library we wanted to avoid any stop
codons or cysteines
I mentioned that we had variable CDR h3
length and the final library size is
approximately 5 times 10 to the ninth
unique clones which is on the high side
for phage libraries and then after
building the library we perform
next-generation sequencing to confirm
that the library reflected the specified
amino acid diversity and length of our
city that we wanted so now I've talked a
lot about the phage panning process and
our specific SCP stage library but now I
want to talk about the antigen that we
use for panning to identify TCR mm
acasio fees so we use what's called a
monomer a monomer simply refers to a
soluble HLA peptide complex and a
monomer consists of an MHC class 1 alpha
chain and this is actually just the echo
domain of the HLA molecule and this is
folded together with a peptide of
interest
so for example in our case it can be a
mutant peptide or a wild-type peptide or
any other control peptide that we want
to investigate and this was folded
together with beta 2 microglobulin and
this final monomer complex can be
violated
so the monomer mimics the peptide HLA
complex on the cell surface and the bite
emulation is really useful for our
purposes it allows for easy and dietra
manipulation so
conjugation to streptavidin magnetic
beads or streptavidin Audra's and we're
going to use this conjugation for
panning or for downstream assays what we
frequently do is we conjugate our
monomer to streptavidin Eliza plates so
to go about identifying TCR mimic SEF es
it's actually a very challenging process
because we're looking for an SP Fe that
can distinguish a single amino acid
change in a complex that consists of
around 480 amino acids so to do this
we've developed a series of phage
selection steps to slowly amplify mutant
peptide HLA specific page these steps
consists of three phases the first phase
we called the enrichment phase so at the
beginning of round 1 we take library
phage and we perform negative selection
by incubate in our phage with
streptavidin magnetic beads as well as
denatured monomer so in every prep of
monomer there's going to be some
denatured monomer and so we want to
remove any phage that would bind to the
denatured HLA and then we take
non-binding phage and then perform
positive selection where we incubate the
phage with a mutant peptide HLA monomer
conjugated to stripped avidin magnetic
beads and after around an hour we wash
those beads and Aleut with acidic
conditions and we amplify that phage by
infecting e.coli with the alluded page
as well as helper phage and we grow the
e.coli overnight to produce more phage
and then we repeat this process
typically around 2 more times so that's
the enrichment phase the second phase we
call the competitive phase in this case
we're going to take round 3 phage at the
beginning of round 4
we're still going to perform negative
selection in a similar manner however in
this case we're going to take the
non-binding page and do what we call
competitive panning so a competitive
panning wiko incubate the phage with
both mutant monomer conjugated to
streptavidin magnetic beads
and wild-type monomer conjugated to
streptavidin agarose and in this way we
can set up a competition situation we're
base with a phage that aphasia has
higher binding to the mutant monomer but
may have some low-level binding to the
wild-type monomer can still be isolated
and so what we do is after about an hour
we use a magnet to pull out stage that
are only binding to the mutant monomer
and we can wash these magnetic beads and
similarly we amplify that phage and so
for competitive panning over the course
of round four through eight
we typically drop down the ratio of the
mutant monomer to the wild-type monomer
and thus increases stringency of
competition the final phase is what we
call final selection and in this case
we're going to do negative selection
against the wild-type monomer and other
control monomers to finally get rid of
any phage that would cross react with
either the wild-type peptide or other
places on the HLA molecule and then we
take a non binding page and once again
perform positive selection against the
mutant monomer and we typically repeat
this process one more time
so what you'll notice about this process
is that unlike traditional hybridoma
technology phage display really allows
you to fine-tune the selection process
so with hybridoma technology there
really wouldn't be an easy way to
negative selection positive selection in
vivo
so now I'll provide a case study for one
antigen of interest this is a que rough
G 12v peptide filled it into hlaa 2 so I
mentioned that kfj 12v mutations are the
second most common mutation in Cairo and
hlaa 2 is one of is the most frequent
hlaa a wheel type and the vast majority
of ethnic group so the peptide we're
interested in is a 5 through 14 peptide
and you can see that the g 12v of mutant
peptide and the wild-type peptide only
vary by a single
glycine to valine changed so following
the panning process we tighter the phage
by infecting e.coli with limiting
delusions of phage such that each eco
life will only be infected with a single
phage particle and then we pick single
bacterial colonies and inoculate those
bacterial colonies in a deep 96-well
plate we grow up that bacteria and
infect the bacteria with helper phage
and thus we can produce monoclonal phage
so then we do what's called a monoclonal
Eliza where we tell it the bacteria in
the deep 96-well plates and then we look
at how the sage Laden supernatant sign
to either the mutant peptide HLA complex
or the wild-type peptide HLA complex on
an analyzer plate and then finally after
we identify any hits on the monoclonal
lives of what we do is we amplify hits
for further characterization so this bar
graph represents one of the monoclonal
Eliza's that we saw for the KSG two of
the HLA a to antigen the y-axis is a
readout of the ability of the SVC to
bind to the protein of interest the blue
bars represent individual SC Fe binding
to the mutant KF monomer and the red
bars indicate wild-type KS monomer
binding and what you'll notice is that
for the majority of FC Fe clones here
say either exhibit no binding to either
monomer or they exhibit very similar
binding to both monomers however there
is one clone we call it v10 for the weld
position that exhibited much higher
binding to the mutant monomer than the
wild-type monomer so we re amplified the
d-10 page and characterized it again on
Eliza to confirm that indeed this d-10
clone was specific to the mutant monomer
and did not recognize the wild-type
monomer so then we worked we wanted to
recombinant Lee Express the d-10 SC Fe
for other assays so we worked with axial
mix actually omics is a subsidiary of ab
cam
we worked with them to recombinant li
express our SC fe and bacteria and they
were able to add AC terminal flag tag
that we use for a number of downstream
assays so one of the fasces were was an
Eliza
so this is an example of one of the
Eliza's that we did with a d-10 SC Fe so
once again the y-axis just represents
the SC fe binding ability we test to the
SD Fe at four different concentrations
represented by the different colors and
you can see that when there is no
monomer coded on the strip out in plate
there is no signal with the g 12v hlaa
to monomer and saw a nice solution
signal for other Queiroz hla-a to
peptides including the wild-type 5 to 14
peptide g12c and gTLD we didn't see any
bindings and for other k rest peptides
folded into hlaa 3 similarly we did not
see any binding as well as for other all
other monomers we tested including EGFR
peptides folded into HLA a3 and ela
which is just an HLA issue controlled
peptide folded into a 2 so this was
really promising that our SCC seemed to
be specific on the lives that however
this is only using recombinant protein
on a plastic surface so we wanted to see
if our SCC could actually recognize a
cell surface cup-tied HLA complex as
this is the ultimate goal if we're going
to use it as a therapy so to go about
investigating Satan's is to go about
answering this question we use a cell
type called P 2 cells T cells are a
lymphoblast
suspension cell line that is deficient
in tap meaning that they're very
inefficient of presenting their own
endogenous peptide and you can add a
peptide eggs honestly and they will
present that peptide and this is
referring referred to as pulsing t2
cells with a peptide and this is a
really good way to determine the
specificity of the SCC for various
peptide a chelate complexes
so well we did various t2 peptide
posting experiments including flow
cytometry so in this case we peptide
post our t2 cells we stained the t2
cells with the D 10 s CF e and we
followed that with an ante slide PE
secondary so the y axis the diagrams
below or just histograms and the y axis
represents the cell count the x axis
represents the ability of the FCC to
bind to cell with increasing binding to
the right and you can see with the first
histogram on the left side we're
comparing chaos wild-type peptide post
t2 cells versus mutant peptide post
Picchu cells both of which are staying
with the D 10 SEC and you see nice
separation between the two curves
similarly for all other hlaa two
peptides we tested there is no seat and
a CF e binding from one of the other
hlaa to subsides we tested we call ll g
and we also didn't see any binding and
importantly if you look at the histogram
on the right when you take mutant
peptide pulse t2 cells and don't stain
them with the SVC you don't see any
binding or you know that you still see
that nice separation between mutant post
cells and all of their conditions so we
took our D 10 SEC and we wanted to
convert it to a full-length antibody so
to do this we simply replace the CDRs in
the 45 antibody called Trish souza map
with this CDRs and our DEET nsdap to
produce a fully human
IgG one antibody and then we transfected
the heavy plasmas with a heavy and light
chains of our D 10 antibody into heck 2
9 3 cells per recombinant expression and
then we wanted to test as frequently
with SCC grafting
sometimes the SCC does not retain the
specificity as a full-length antibody so
we did various downstream asses
confirm that indeed our antibody
retained the d-10 specific binding so in
this experiment it's a slow cytometry
experiment where we peptide pulse t2
cells and in this case we've stained
with a d-10 antibody followed by an
anti-human PE secondary and if you look
at the histogram on the left this is
comparing wild-type peptide pools T 2
cells represented by the black dotted
line versus mutant peptide coasties 2
cells represented by the solid red line
and you still see the nice separation
between the mutant peptide po cells
versus wild-type and similarly for other
hlaa two peptides we tested like ela we
see this same separation remained and
then if you look at the histogram on the
right side of the screen you can see
when the mutant peptide pulls T 2 cells
are stained with an iso type control
antibody you so sees about the same
level of separation between mutant
peptide pool cells staying with the v10
Manta body versus all other controls so
this was really promising but we wanted
to see if we could affinity mature or
d-10 clone so we want to think about
using the deep end SC Fe or full-length
antibody as a therapeutic we thought
that we might need a higher affinity
given the fact that we don't think the
antigen density on tumor cells is
necessarily going to be very high so we
worked with axial mix to a committee
mature the d-10 clone we've provided
axial mix with the d-10 sed sequence and
they generated a sage library over a B
10 sec variance using their axial mix
error prone PCR mutagenesis and their
final library size was around 10 to the
80 neutrons and then Axio mix perform
panning they did three rounds each
consisting of negative selection against
the wild-type monomer followed by
positive selection against the mutant
monomer at the end of panning axiom
excrete a tea
colonies on Eliza all of which
recognizing mutant monomer and then they
sequence a top 16 clones that gave the
highest signals of which eight were
unique
so then Axio mix to do to do follow-up
characterization on these eight unique
clones they were commonly produced these
SUVs and tested them on various Eliza's
so now we'll give you some examples of
the Eliza's that up axiom experimental
Aiza was just to see how the parental D
10 SC Fe and its eight affinity matured
variants bound to the wild-type monomer
so axial mix is referring to the
parental d-10 SUV as a XM - 8 9 4 and
this Eliza the wild-type monomer was
coated at a high concentration and each
of the recombinant SCO fees either
the prints will be 10 or one of the
affinity and matured variants was
incubated with the wild-type monomer and
you can see that like the print will be
10
none of the affinity maturing variants
had any wild-type monomer body and this
is really impressive so frequently with
affinity maturation you may see some
increased liability for other antigens
that you do not want your SVD to bind to
however in this case we were able to get
eight different affinity matured
variants all of which exhibited no
wild-type monomer binding and the next
Eliza that axiom exper formed this is a
they did a titration Eliza and in this
case they coded mutant monomers at
different concentrations as shown on the
x-axis and they incubated the mutant
monomer in each well with either the
parental d-10 FCC represented by the
light green line or one of the affinity
matured variants and you can see that
the parental D tennesippi gives the
lowest signal for each concentration of
mutant monomer all affinity matured
variants gave a higher signal
representing higher affinity
so in summary all eight variants had
improved mutant monomer peptide HLA
binding with no wild-type peptide a
tional a bonding so then we wanted to
see if we're going to use the d-10 FC
fee as a therapeutic it needs to be able
to kill cells that present the peptide
HLA complex so we did what's called a
complement dependent cytotoxicity assay
and this is where you basically mix an
antibody containing at the FC that binds
to a particular target cell and you mix
this antibody the target cell and
complement and the antibody will fix
complement via its FC region and kill
that target cell and the CDC assay we
were comparing the d-10 SAV to one of
the affinity matured variants the axiom
X record identified and recall this
affinity matured variant D tendashseven
in this case we were using v5 tagged FCS
and what we did is we pre conjugated the
SCV to a full length and tv5 antibody
and that's because as I mentioned to
carry out a CDC essay you need that
full-length antibody containing an FC
region two six complement on the target
cell surface so this is an example of
the results that we saw with our CDC
essay so I'll just walk you through the
diagram the x-axis represents different
concentration of the s DfE antibody
conjugates the y-axis represents
specific cell death the blue line our
unposted two cells incubated with
various concentrations of the affinity
matured me tendashseven
SVC conjugated to the ante v5 antibody
and you can see that at all
concentrations tested we essentially see
no cell death similarly when you
incubate the D 10-7 affinity maturity
with a wild type type type t2
you see very minimal sawdust however
when you incubate the assuming you
mature D 10-7 SDC conjugated an tv5 with
the mutant peptide close to two cells
you see nice dilutional killing of the
t2 cells within ec50 around 0.8 nano
molar and this is actually in sharp
contrast the parental d-10 FCC which
only have an EC 50 of around 11 nano
molar so this demonstrates not only can
we use our sco fees for a killing assay
but that the affinity matured variants
perform much better than the original
d-10 and are far more sensitive so in
summary we've designed and built an FCC
base page library we can isolate SCP is
that specifically recognized mutant
peptide HLA complexes over the wild-type
counterparts we've identified FCC's at
this point for a number of different
mutant upside HLA complexes including
the KSG 12 e peptide in hlaa - we've
been able to successfully convert our G
12 EA to clone d-10 into a full-length
human IgG one antibody as well as
working with axial mix we were able to
affinity mature that SAV the higher
affinity variants and then finally what
we're currently working on right now and
I didn't show any data on this today but
we're working on converting our SUVs and
to therapeutically useful formats so I
mentioned that we've converted our SUV
into a full-length antibody but this may
not be the most sensitive killing method
for a therapeutic so we're working on
converting an SUV into very potent
killing formats including card t-cells
by specific antibodies and antibody drug
conjugates and then finally I want to
just make a quick plug for axial mixes
services because axial mixes services
really made this project possible we
worked with axiom mix on multiple
aspects of the project so axial mix
provides custom SUV expression services
where they provide affordable SCC preps
we
the tag that you desire on the SCV they
can affinity mature and SCC and I
mentioned I about how they allowed us to
do the panning process so they we worked
with we've worked at this point with
actually mix on a number of different
affinity maturation projects and they've
allowed us to customize how we want to
do that stage standing process and then
finally I didn't talk about this today
but we're currently working with axial
mix on by specific se of the expression
and both bacterial bacterial and
mammalian systems including diabetes and
SC at the FCS and then per labs that do
not have their own sage library and do
not want to build their own sage library
axial mix provides custom discovery
screening using their own axiom ectasia
library and then finally I just want to
relate that this was a team effort this
project was a team effort I worked with
a postdoc Andrew score and another
graduate student Michael Wong on all
aspects of the project I also want to
thank my P is Burt kinship and Nick and
Louise as well as the service providers
AB cam and axial mix the Hopkins Kimmel
Cancer Center flow cytometry core as
well as the Fred hutch immune monitoring
core Fred hutch provided all the HLA
monomers that we used in this study and
then now I want to hand the presentation
over to Sam Bob who will talk more about
the axial mix phage display platform
Thank You Jackie for sharing your
project with us following on the team
from Jackie's presentation I would like
to tell you about Afghans efforts to
generate recombinant antibodies using
axiom exposed Espeland form Afghan Serbs
life science researchers globally from
sites in North America Europe and Asia
with innovative reagents and tools AB
camp provides the research and clinical
communities with highly validated
biological binders and assays to study
important protein targets in critical
biological pathways so recombinant
antibody reagents offer many advantages
over traditional antibodies the comment
on antibodies can be designed to meet
your exact requirements they can be
engineered towards specific affinity and
the right applications including IHC
flow cytometry and western blotting they
are highly versatile in the applications
they are routinely developed as
humanized therapeutic agents and SCF
fees can be incorporated into an IgG
framework for either diagnostic or
research use they can be engineered into
chimeric antigen receptors and also by
specific antibodies recommen antibodies
of a high level of consistency across
batches of the reagent and new batches
of the antibody can be produced very
quickly when compared to traditional
methods when it comes to picking the
right platform to discover antibodies no
single approach is suitable for all
requirements and at that gam we have the
choice to use ab cam rad map rabbit
monoclonal platform or the axiom X phage
display platform each offering distinct
advantages the rad bab antibodies
discussed in detail in our other
webinars of a high affinity antibody
binders when compared to mouse
honors the rabid immune system can
recognize diverse epitope and the
affinity maturation of the antibody
occurs in vivo the Axio mix phage
display platform became available to ad
cam following acquisition of axiom
extinct in November 2015 it is a rapid
and devoid discovery platform which uses
phage display library to drive the
discovery the affinity maturation of the
antibody occurs in vitro using axiom X
near to Genesis and today I'd like to
tell you about tell you more about the
axiom explains display platform the
platform consists of m13 SC SC phage mid
library and the library contains more
than 10 to the power of 10 clones the
library is highly diverse with less than
10% Banton clones and the mutations are
focused in the CDR region the platform
offers rapid liquid screening which is
performed in antigen coated wells the in
vitro affinity maturation is performed
using axiom X mutagenesis which is
thousand times more efficient when
compared to error prone PCR alone it
combines site-directed mutagenesis and
error prone PCR you create a library
with 10 to the power of 8 clones
distinct clones the platform can also
use wholesale panning and screen for
binders against a membrane-bound
antigens on the cell surface this
ensures that the binders are screened
for desired XSL the epitope of the cell
surface protein the academics platform
have distinct advantages over
traditional methods of antibody
discovery apart from engineering binders
against protein targets that include
peptides and fragments the platform is
highly suited to generate binders
against post translationally modified
proteins it can also generate high
affinity binders to antigens that fail
to induce an immune response
or against non protein antigens where
traditional methods fail to produce
usable antibodies the platform is
uniquely able to generate binders
against against difficult antigens that
can be toxic to an in vivo system a key
advantage of the phage display is that
binders can be engineered for the
desired applications the hybridomas can
be converted to recombinant antibodies
and properties of an existing antibody
can also be further optimized so the
axiom explant form is divided into two
main phases the first phase is the
discovery phase and the second is the
affinity maturation phase in the
discovery phase of the fvfv development
using the diverse phage library the goal
is to identify candidate as CFP clones
that bind to the target with the desired
specificity in the affinity maturation
phase the SC SC IDs efvs identified in
the discovery phase is then further
enhanced by improving its affinity
multiple fold this is achieved using
axial mix mutagenesis and additional
rounds of rapid liquid screening the
final SC FV is then further
characterized in the desired
applications and can be converted to a
full IgG antibody the rapid liquid
screening approach that is used in axial
mix platform uses antigen coated wells
this eliminates the need for any solid
phase by opening the phage library is
incubated in multi-well plates coated
with the antigen of choice and the rels
are then washed to remove any unbound
phage the bound stage then eluted and
the eluded stages can be either
subjected to further rounds of screening
for high specificity or selected as
candidate clones for characterization
the affinity maturation helps enhance
the affinity of the candidate binder the
Axio mix mutagenesis uses a set of
mutagenic primers and combined with
error prone PCR create a phage library
derived from the candidate clone this
newly generated library is again
screened against the antigen to get the
desired affinity so when compared to
when comparing axiom is mutagenesis -
error prone PCR alone the axiom is
mutagenesis offers greater diversity in
the phage light the phage library and an
increased rate in increased rate of
mutation so affinity maturation can also
help improve the properties of the
identified binder here we have shown
previously how affinity maturation can
improve the stability of the binder and
also help enhance the affinity of a
given binder the graph on the right
shows easing affinity maturation we were
able to improve on the original clone
and achieve a 300 fold increase in the
affinity for the antigen and the graph
on the left hand side shows how affinity
maturation improved the thermal
stability of another binder the original
binder lost nearly 85 percent of its
activity when within seven and a half
minutes at 70 degrees centigrade using
affinity maturation we were we enable
the binder to remain active for over 60
minutes at 70 degrees so the techniques
used in axiom X platform has been
published in several peer-reviewed
journals the link to the articles can be
found in further reading section of this
webinar the articles go in detail about
the techniques including the wholesale
tanning process
and the affinity maturation process you
can also learn about other techniques
using the academics platform including
emulsion panning and SCS v2 IgG sub
cloning
which I did not get to time which I did
not get to talk about today and to learn
more about Afghans efforts to develop
recombinant antibodies please visit this
link below so in summary the axiom
x-rays display platform is a versatile
method for rapid phage display antibody
development it is fast and effective and
applicable to broad uses in life science
research so using recombinant antibodies
at cam continues to improve antibody
based assays and we have developed a
number of single Plex and multiplex
assays using recombinant antibodies with
this I will end my part of the
presentation and and I would like to
thank Jackie again for her presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type in type
them in the Q&A box found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and Jackie
and I will answer as many questions as
time permits
so the first question is have you been
able to identify specific SEO fees to
each mutant peptide HLA complex you
stand against yep sim Bob so that's a
really good question we have at this
point pan for around 20 to 30 unique
peptide HLA antigens and I would say
that we've been able to identify SCPs
that are specific for about half of
those antigens and I think that's true
for a number of different reasons in
some cases the mutant amino acid might
be buried and the HLA cleft and so the
mutant peptide and the wild-type peptide
are going to look very similar in the
HLA complex we've also noticed that it
seems to be a little bit easier to
identify FCPS that recognize hydrophobic
amino acids so what I would say in
summary is that about half the time we
can identify FCPS and some antigens have
proved to be far more difficult than
others so
great another question is if a pet died
it's predicted to bind to a given HLA
allele what is the chance that is
actually presented yep so this is a hot
area of tumor immunology right now so we
know that not all peptides that are
predicted to bind to a given HLA allele
will actually be presented so there's
other variables along the way that
Popeil has to be properly processed by
the proteasome and loaded onto the HLA
Kampai
and so no not all peptides will bind to
given HLA allele your sorry not all
peptides predicted deveined will
actually be presented on the cell
surface and so we and other groups are
currently doing mass spec and other
assays to try to confirm that these
peptides are actually presented okay I
have another question for you Jackie
given that given that the phage library
only introduces diversity in the CDR how
important is diversity in the CDRs
versus in the framework region yep yeah
that's a that's a really good question
so because our phage library can only be
of a particular size we wanted to
introduce diversity in the region that
we thought would be the most important
and this is a CDRs however what we've
noticed with the affinity matured
variants so I should say that with
affinity maturation you can get
mutations and both the CDRs and the
framework region and what we've noticed
is that many of the affinity matured
variants have framework mutations and
this seemed to provide increased
affinity great so there's another
question can s CFPs be converted to full
IgG ease and I can I can answer that yes
the SPF ease can be put into an IgG
framework and and we and actually omics
has multiple vector vector framework
options that can be used
the next question is do a CF V's work in
IHC yep so yeah I can answer that so SDA
do work and I immunohistochemistry we've
done this many times I didn't show any
that data today but all you have to do
is incubate yourselves with the SCP of
interest and then follow that with the
appropriate secondary antibody so yes
they do work well in IHC yeah and from
from app cams perspective yes we can
test the clones to ensure that they they
are screened for buoyancy so the next
question is how do you device the phage
library of SC FES
oh yeah yeah and you can add to that so
a taxi omics the scse library is a human
synthetic library prepared by combining
gene sequences together with randomized
CDRs and to produce the phage library
Jackie do you want to add on to how have
you developed your laundry yep so just
just the converse so there's usually two
ways that you can think of the age
library the first is that you can take
endogenous b-cell receptors from people
even sequence those and you can make a
phage library from those sequences the
other way which is a way that we did is
that we just it's a purely synthetic DNA
sequence freeze in the 45 framework and
we're using various degenerate
oligonucleotide technology to vary the
amino acids and the CDRs great so we
have another question for you
Jackie could you describe your NGS
strategy targeted or shotgun Reaper and
what the read length and the sequencing
instrument used
yep so we use a my seat redesigned
primers that's linked CDRs h2 and h3 our
amplicon I believe is around 150 to 200
nucleotides and so we were looking at
diversity in the CDR h2 and h3 region
okay what software did you use to
analyze the NGS data for your original
libraries so our lab does a lot of
sequencing and we have an in-house
pipeline to analyze data but some of the
analysis I did I just did with Excel but
that was very down stream analysis okay
another question on affinity maturation
how do you make sure that the affinity
maturation of the antibody undergoes all
the steps that normally occur in a lymph
nodes so the affinity maturation we're
doing would be different than what
happens in gaja honestly so there's a
number of different physiological steps
that occurred in the lymph node it's
going to be a different process but the
result is still similar and that we're
getting variation and the CDRs and in
the framework region I believe from my
medical school classes that most of the
diversity that would occur in an
endogenous b-cell receptor is going to
occur in the CDRs I don't think you're
going to see as many framework mutations
so I think it's a slightly it's a
different process okay the other
question is for me
so does Axio mix have access to use scse
library for discovery yes we do have a
selection of libraries that we can use
for discovery of effect of NSERC
and I think we have time for one last
question and that is for Jackie I have a
question regarding the selection of
cancer associated mutation is there any
criteria and how can we predict peptide
actually binding yep so our goal is just
to help the most number of patients
possible so our criteria we look at two
things we look at the mutation frequency
and the HLA allele frequency so we've
created a score to basically we've
predicted all peptides containing common
mutations and we predicted which of
those peptides will bind a common HLA
allele and we've created a score just
in-house to rank various mutant peptide
HLA complexes so basically that's our
criteria other things that we care about
is any evidence in the literature to
suggest that that particular mutant
peptide is actually presented this
evidence could be mass spec evidence or
it could be t-cell based evidence well
thank you Jackie
so I'd like to think I in that audience
yep so I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions we'd like to thank
lab roots for organizing this and also
AB camp for underwriting today's
educational webcast please note a short
survey has appeared for you to answer we
appreciate your feedback on the survey
as we work to plan for future webinars
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through June 2017 and lab routes will
alert you by email when it's available
for replaying we encourage you to share
the email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event so until
next time goodbye